that's how kids drink when they like it
gas more gas more gas more hey what's up
gqueues man my caps knees my centuries
for soul glasses these are German /
soles and they got a little T in them if
you can see in the eyes you can see our
Arnold Palmer in there so you ain't just
seeing my regular eyes got a little
shade on it I can wear them with
anything t-shirt hat su these are
vintage these glasses were made in 50s
these are an original pair that I bought
from a vintage store in LA I can't tell
you the name of it cuz you might try to
go get them but it's in Compton I know
you ain't going down there my two-part
bracelet this is Tupac Shakur's bracelet
this bracelet right here is the exact
bracelet that's one of the eyes on me
album cover so if you go look at the
album cover and his arm is leaning on
there with the bracelet this is it right
here I've been a Tupac plan since the
first album I thought I would have never
ever got anything that had something to
do with I did a couple projects with
Miss Afeni Shakur rest in peace in
Atlanta at the Atlanta Tupac Center and
they gifted me with this bracelet now
this bracelet right here it means so
much to hip-hop greatest rapper alive
[Music]
I'll always cherish this this is my good
luck even if it's just in my bag you
know I just have good luck I'm gonna
keep it in eventually returning to the
Shakur family but right now I'm using it
for a little power
you know this is a trail mix this is an
exquisite trail mix it's got all types
of different varieties in it it has
almonds in it it has cashews raising one
of them has chocolate in it you know
when I wanted a little sweet tooth but
this is so great to have man to carry on
the role with you it keeps me from
stopping and McDonald's and getting that
Big Mac that I've been eating my whole
life I carry it everywhere sometime I be
on the stage I might have a few almonds
in my back pocket why the crowd laughing
OOP looka here looka here looka here man
that's the vintage waffle cones this is
the first Nike that was ever made not
this one particular but this style I had
the original waffle cones and I warm
down the shoe is so old the heel is in
the front but I have over at least 2,500
pair of sneakers still in the box
these are my favorite you can wear these
with anything soup you can wear them
with shorts t-shirt and they feel so
good on your feet you can exercise in
these you can wear them casually and get
away from the police mine existential
was my popcorn
skinny pop I got the head and skinny pop
my wife turned me on the skinny pop cuz
I was eating regular pop and the regular
pop had me pop pop pop so I started
eating the skinny pop and I got skinnier
now I'm not telling people if you eat
this popcorn you're gonna get skinny you
got to do some other stuff with the
skinny pop but this is a great popcorn
don't have a lot of salt on it it's
really light
bring it on a plane with me you can find
yourself eating the whole bag if you
won't be careful skinny pop get your bag
this is my iPod another vintage piece a
lot of you guys not familiar with this
especially Nugent
but it has over 7,000 songs on it
I got a jazz mix on here I got a Latin
playlist I got a line dance I got Mike
so play this NWA eazy-e doctor I got a
fun party playlist I got a I got rap I
got new school rap I got real good
riding hits I got Mike simplemind got
rock out food fighters police Warner
Tears for Fears todo you've got to get
you one of these you just gotta go back
in time and get it you know I gotta have
this marshal box right here because as
we all know everybody has a soundtrack
to their own life this is what equips me
with my soundtrack I really love music
classic to jazz hip hop Calypso reggae
it's old-school
it's got like a 70s vibe and this box
right here I mean it bumps I mean old
people don't like the sound of it funky
days it's just putting my backseat some
time let it bump in the car Fiji water
right here this is what keep me hydrated
this is gonna keep me going make me feel
good
keep me regular you know keep me flushed
out make me feel like I'm a human being
this is the best water that is for me
that I like to drink there's so many
other waters but when you pop the top
you hear like a that's like coca-cola
hey GQ those are my essentials preset
y'all watch